jean paul hamon il est président de
l'association des médecins de france est
médecin généraliste
jean paul hamon merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors en tant
que médecin est ce que vous saluer cette
stratégie de différencier les
départements pour éviter une seconde
vague ont écouté que le département soit
soit vert rouge orange ça change pas
grand chose c'est à dire qu' il va
falloir que les médecins généralistes
soient soient mobilisés pour identifier
et répertorier les personnes positives
de façon à ce qu'on puisse identifier
également les personnes contactées de
façon à pouvoir confiné rapidement les
les personnes qu'on doit qu'on doit
protéger pour éviter la contagion donc
dans tous les départements les médecins
généralistes seront là même on rend la
même attitude là la vraie question c'est
est ce qu'on aura le droit d'en dans
deux trois quatre semaines le droit de
changer de région de passer d'une rouge
à une jaune ou d'une chaude à une verte
et inversement donc la question et c'est
la seule que tous les français se posent
en ce moment en tout cas est ce qu'avec
cette stratégie là il y a quand même un
risque de deuxième rax cette deuxième
rac temps redouté et quelles en seraient
les causes
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas de deuxième
bagaya il ya une seule et même vague là
actuellement on à freiner l'épidémie
grâce au confinement
on a réussi à soulager les hôpitaux
grâce au confinement a soulagé les lits
de réanimation qui sont quand même un
flux tendu avec du personnel qui n'est
pas extensible à l'infini
donc il fallait absolument diminuer la
pression sur les lits de réanimation et
contrôler le
le redémarrage et contrôler leur
démarrage de l'épidémie
parce que forcément avec le confinant
avec le déconfinement même si c'est un
déconfinement extrêmement prudent il va
y avoir de nouveaux cas qui vont qui
vont se produire
et c'est cela qu'il faudra identifier
contrôler confiné et pour éviter que de
nouveaux les hospitaliers soit soient
surchargées et c'est pour ça que le
système doit doit faire preuve là cette
fois ci de cette efficacité parce que
les médecins généralistes cette fois ci
seront protégés avec des masques sans
doute j'espère pour des lunettes et des
charlotte et des blues pour ce qui
concerne les prélèvements et puis ainsi
on pourra confiné l'excellente a limité
l'extension de l'épidémie et éviter que
l'hôpital ne soit débordé alors
justement concernant la tension des
capacités hospitalières
est-ce qu'il est encore nécessaire de
déplacer des malades dans différentes
régions voire les départements en rouge
est ce que ce serait une solution de
déplacer les malades dans des
départements en zone jaune ou vert par
exemple
non mais là maintenant il n'y a plus il
n'y a plus aucune zone qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient débordés en réanimation
tout tout les leaders et aurélie de
réanimation ont été ont été soulagés
même si c'est quand même extrêmement
extrêmement tendue donc là il est plus
question de déménager des délits des
personnes en réanimation d'une région à
une autre
alors en tout cas il est question des
tests vous vous en parliez tout à
l'heure c'est l'un des derniers
paramètres de la capacité des
départements s'est testé détecter les
personnes en contact avec le virus dans
les ces fameux département zone rouge
on le voit bien des régions avec une
forte population s et s2 massif est ce
qu'ils sont très concrètement réalisable
aujourd'hui je pense que oui ça va ça va
être réalisable c'est en tous les cas
c'est réalisable en pc ces prélèvements
qu'on fait dans les narines
enfin dans le brabant le fin fond à
parce que si on fait un test juste dans
les d'arrêt de
on a des négatifs qui sont faux mais ce
qu'on attend surtout cesser dès que
qu'on valide les tests sanguins à ceux
qui vont permettre de savoir si si les
gens ont fait le la maladie ou pas parce
que n'oublions pas que beaucoup de
personnes sont touchées sans faire aucun
symptôme alors une autre question pour
pour terminer qui interpelle aussi sur
le virus et cette étude génétique menée
par l'institut pasteur qui laisse
entendre que la diffusion de l'épidémie
en france serait très peu liés à des cas
importés de chine ou d'italie une
troisième souche à l'origine pour
l'instant inconnues expliquerait cette
forte diffusion de l'épidémie dans
l'hexagone
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer à
ce sujet la gta j'ai été un peu surpris
quand j'ai lu ça ce matin effectivement
est ce que c est ce que c'est quand même
pas une mutation du virus est ce que
c'est pas quand même c'est quand même là
la coïncidence est quand même troublante
l'italie l'italie aurait des cas
importés
et nous on n'aurait pas de cas importés
moi je suis persuadé que ce qui s'est
passé en rhône alpes auvergne
ou quand même on a assisté à une flambée
de cas à parti quinze jours après le
match contre de la juventus contre
contrôlions avec en plus le quelques
jours plus tard où quelques jours et
quelques jours plus tard le match lyon
saint-etienne qui a de nouveau bras
c'est là la population de rhône alpes
auvergne
donc il ya eu trois grands matchs de
foot dans dans cette région et et quinze
jours après le match mais le tus turin
il ya eu une flambée des cas on a le
problème ne se sont pas des cas de de la
contamine montjoie qui des
contamines-montjoie qui on est et qui
ont été à l'origine de cette de cette
flambée donc incontestablement c'est
quinze jours après le match juventus
turin
donc je comprendrais mal faudrait quand
même aller voir du côté de rhône alpes
auvergne si c'est quand même pas le même
virus que le virus italia ce que je
pense merci beaucoup jean paul hamon
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association des médecins de
ces médecins généralistes